how's Vsauce doin Michael here and today
I'm talking mods not console mods though
this guy who just freakin microwaved his
ps3 deserves an honorable mention
instead I'm talking about modifications
of games I'm gonna start with grand
theft auto
not the car gun but this vehicle mod
that gives Nico a skateboard and here's
a combination of the two games I've
dedicated most of 2010 to World of
Warcraft models in Starcraft 2 notice
the health bars in the click to move
love it let's rewind to mid - I couldn't
find any video of this mod in action but
it represents a history nerd angle that
I love it's called blue vs. gray no not
red vs. blue blue vs. grey and it allows
you to fast-forward the game from
medieval times to the American Civil War
how about this body Mass Effect 2 so
that Shepherd is a girl see it's a nice
equal-opportunity mod of course it also
allows famous scenes like this to become
well different the original Unreal
Tournament was the first game I played
secretly without parental approval point
is I love this mod of the ps3 version of
Unreal Tournament 3 it lets you play as
halos masters but why stop there the
more layers of modern is the better so
why not put halo 3 in Unreal Tournament
and then stick the whole thing inside a
side-scrolling Super Mario Brothers game
this is like digital turducken while
we're talking Super Mario here it is a
first-person game with a map made in
half-life 2 not enough freedom well
let's put Mario in Vice City the mod
that impresses me the most is this
Simpsons map for quake 3 it's super
famous because the attention to detail
is incredible and it doesn't stop with
the interior of the house either so
that's my list there are so many other
great mods out there I would love to
hear back from you guys tell me what
your favorites are and let us know where
we can get them and/or see them in
action
these aren't mods at all they're just
people doing what the game is for but
that are neat enough I had to include
them you know things like this luxury
vehicle from LittleBigPlanet
this guy who's building a working 16-bit
arithmetic computer inside minecraft yes
he's building a computer inside a video
game on his computer wants something
bigger well how about this guy he's
building a one to one scale model of the
enterprise in Minecraft yes that's right
one to one actual size he's got the
entire frame finished but he's looking
for people to help him finish the Dex
you can check him out in his channel by
following a link in this video's
description I've also put links to all
of these mods in action there stay tuned
Friday for a special countdown for Mikey
gamer of the top fall games until next
time thanks for watching
[Music]